we're on problem 107
107.
any decimal that has only a finite
number of non-zero digits
is a terminating decimal for example
the examples to give is 24
0.82
and 5.096
so they're saying if you just have a
finite number of these non-zero things
at some point you have to end and have
zeros just left over so that's what they
mean by a terminating decimal if r and s
are positive integers so r
and s
are positive integers
so positive
integers
and the ratio r divided by s is
expressed as a decimal
so r divided by s
so that is expressed as a decimal is r
divided by s a terminating decimal
r divided by s terminating
so essentially it wouldn't work if r and
n if this is one third that's not going
to work because you're going to have 0.3
forever so they're saying does it at
some point end this is interesting
so statement 1
tells us that 90
is less than r
which is less than
that statement by itself doesn't help me
let's say that r was i don't know let's
say that r was uh
let me think of a
of a good
r so 90
let's say r was 93
if r is equal to 93
and then
s
is equal to well let's just say that s
for the sake of argument is three times
r
right actually i don't i don't have to
pick an r
whatever r is i can just pick an s to be
three times r
right and i'm not going to get a
terminating decimal on the other hand if
i pick s to be 2 times r
then i'm going to have a terminating
decimal so statement 1 by itself isn't
going to help me
right
statement number 2. i hope you
understand that i can pick any s to make
it terminating or not at this point no
matter whether you know r is constrained
to between 90 and 100.
statement 2 tells us
statement 2 tells us that
s is equal to 4
b
s
is equal to four
b
now this is interesting to me so where
did this b come from all of a sudden
any decimal that has only a finite
number of non-zero digits is a
terminating decimal for example okay
if r and s rx are integers
and the ratio
s is equal to 4b where did this come
from
let me look up what is what is
i think this is a typo
because i'm where did where did b come
from all of a sudden
oh yeah when i look at the solution they
say s is equal to four
so that's a that's definitely a typo 4b
s is equal to 4. okay that makes a lot
more sense
all right so if s is equal to 4 pretty
much any number when you divide any
number by 4 you're going to have a
terminating decimal it's either going to
be divisible by 4
or it's going to be some you know the
worst case if you have 1 divided by 4
that equals 0.25 so no matter what when
you divide something by 4 you're always
going to have a determining decimal it's
never going to repeat forever i mean you
can try it out with every every you know
no matter which of these no matter what
number you you divide if you view it as
a fraction or kind of your fourth grade
remainder problems the remainder is
either going to be one
two or 3. if the remainder is 1 the
decimal is going to be 0.25 if the
remainder is 2 the decimal is going to
be 0.5 and the remainder is 3 the
decimal is going to be 0.75
in any case as long as s equals 4 you
have a terminating decimal so statement
two alone is sufficient and statement
one really doesn't tell us much
and i'm annoyed that they had that b
typo there
next problem
108.
okay they've drawn a triangle
they've drawn a triangle
right there let's let me see if i can
draw it properly
okay and it looks like it looks like a
all right
there you go
and let me label it so this is b
that's a
that's c this is y degrees and this is d
and this is x degrees
in the figure above what is the value of
x plus y so x degrees plus y degrees x
plus y is equal to what
all right question number one so they
don't tell us anything else they don't
tell us this is an equilateral triangle
they don't tell us that these angles are
equal they don't tell us it's symmetric
they don't tell us anything about this
triangle so far so statement number one
tells us that x is equal to 70.
well just by x equaling 70 that still
doesn't help me i still don't know what
y can be i mean you could draw this
interior triangle in a bunch of
different ways you can see that the
angle could change depending on how much
you lift up d or compress d this y angle
can change irrespective of what x is so
x is equal to 70 does not in any way
give me any information on what y is
statement two
triangle a
b c
and triangle
a
dc
are both isosceles
isosceles so isosceles means that these
two sides
well
actually it doesn't mean necessarily
that those are those two sides are the
same
i mean that that's kind of tends to be
someone's immediate assumption when you
say sassy so maybe that side is equal to
that side but no it just means that two
of the sides are the same
so likewise on this triangle
although you can at least
here can i make an argument
now you can't make an argument which two
sides are going to be the same
so even if you assumed that both of
those sides are the same
you're still not going to because you
don't know you know my gut instinct
would say oh that side's the same as
that side but no i can't make that
assumption
because it could be that this side is
equal to this side that would still make
an isosceles and this side is kind of
used like the base side
it's a very big difference because if
these are the two equal sides and if
this is x this is going to be x
but then if i take the other scenario
where if these are two sides and if this
is x then both of these are going to be
180 minus x divided by 2 right
because this would be you know the
bottom line is this still doesn't get me
anywhere even if i know that this is 70
degrees so i'm going to go with e
not enough information to solve this
problem
are positive integers p and q both
greater than n
so p
q
greater than n and they're positive
integers they already told us that
positive integers
okay
they say p
minus q is greater than n
p
minus q
is greater than n well i give you a case
right now where that doesn't satisfy
this what if
what if
p
is equal to 10
q is equal to one
then
then we you know and n is equal to two
right then 10 minus 1 is 9 is definitely
greater than 2 but look q is not greater
than
2. 1 is not greater than 2. so q
wouldn't be greater than n or i could
say you know it could be
i don't know 110
and 108
would equal and when you subtract you
get two and in this case q is bigger
than two
so this doesn't give me enough
information i can think of two
combinations or two combinations of pq's
and n's one that says that
q is not greater than n and one that
says that q is greater than n
so one by itself isn't enough
statement two
q
q is greater than p
that still doesn't help me and even if i
used i mean
both of these both of these statements
actually cannot be true simultaneously
because if these are both positive
integers which they told us right
if they're both positive integers
well
greater than n both greater than n they
didn't tell us necessary that n is
positive
so n doesn't have to be positive
my logic for statement 1 still holds but
let's see if q is greater than
p
if q is greater than p if if this by
itself doesn't help me much because i
can think of a similar combination to
this right i could say q
i could say q
you know
q is equal to 10 p is equal to 9 and i
could make n is equal to 2 or i could
say n is equal to
n is equal to
right this in no way constrains what n
is so it by itself doesn't solve it but
what if we were to use both constraints
this is the interesting case
what if we were to say
that p
minus q is greater than n
and q is greater than p
so
we know that both p and q are positive
they told us that in the problem
statement if p and q are both positive
and p
and p sorry and q is greater than p
this is going to end up becoming a
negative number
right these are both positive and this
is the larger of the two positive
numbers based on the second constraint
so this is going to be a negative number
and so if a negative number is greater
than n
then we can be sure we can be positive
that both p and q are greater than n
because they told us that p p and q are
positive
so actually both of these
statements imply that n is negative
n is negative because we have a negative
number here being greater than n and if
n is negative then both p and q are
definitely greater than n so both
statements combined are sufficient to
answer this question and the answer is
actually true
i'll see you in the next video